A trailer for the final season of Game of
Thrones is out.
And it shows that the start of Season 8 is
a lot like the start of Season 1 – with
a queen and a king coming to Winterfell.
But this time, the queen is Daenerys, and
the king is Jon Snow.
Daenerys brings her army of Unsullied, and
a boy watches from above, just like how Bran
watched from above in Episode 1.
Daenerys also brings her dragons – the first
dragons at Winterfell in a over a hundred
years.
There’s a lotta magic and symbolism in these
creatures of fire flying above this icy fortress.
Sansa Stark has never seen dragons and magic
before.
Most of her story has been in the south with
the political plots, so she was uncomfortable
last season, with psychic Bran and Faceless
Arya.
If Season 8 is all about fantastical magical
battles – how will Sansa and her skills
fit in?
Sansa has enjoyed ruling Winterfell – will
Queen Daenerys threaten her power?
Arya also sees her first dragon – and she’s
excited.
She’s always wanted adventure and freedom
and power – and that’s what dragons represent
. Arya is a fan of Visenya Targaryen , a dragon
queen from hundreds of years ago.
So maybe Arya will also like Daenerys, this
new dragon queen.
We see Jon and Daenerys with the dragons,
Rhaegal and Drogon – Rhaegal is the green
one, and Drogon the red one.
Daenerys rides Drogon – it’s named after
her first husband, Drogo.
And Rhaegal is named after Rhaegar Targaryen.
Rhaegar is Daenerys’ brother, and Jon’s
real father.
So maybe Jon will ride Rhaegal.
There could be a cute montage of Daenerys
teaching Jon to ride – oh wait we already
saw that.
The dragons have a bunch of blackened bones
– which was probably their breakfast.
But we heard least season that Winterfell
doesn’t have enough food for its people
– so will they be able to feed two giant
dragons?
If they get too hungry, they might start eating
people, which was a problem in Meereen.
Daenerys used to have three dragons – but
Viserion was killed and taken by the Night
King.
Can Drogon and Rhaegal defeat their undead
sibling?
Jon stands in the Winterfell godswood.
This is where Ned Stark came to pray and contemplate.
Jon thinks that Ned is his father.
But last season, Bran and Sam learned the
truth – that Jon is the son of Rhaegar and
Lyanna . Sam plans to tell Jon about his parents
, and he looks worried.
Cause the truth will make Jon and Dany’s
relationship a lot more complicated .For one
thing, it means that Daenerys is Jon’s aunt
– and they boatsexed.
But also, Daenerys’ identity is built on
her being “the last Targaryen” , heir
to the Throne.
If Jon is the true heir, ahead of Daenerys
– what has Dany been fighting for all this
time?
It also questions Jon’s identity – is
he a Stark or a Targaryen, a bastard or a
king?
It looks like Jon and Dany have a D&M in the
Winterfell crypts, possibly by the statue
of Jon’s real mother, Lyanna.
This again parallels Episode 1, when Ned and
Robert discuss Lyanna in the crypts.
We also see Tyrion, who was very concerned
last season about Jon and Dany’s relationship.
How will he react to Jon’s true parentage?
And whose side is Tyrion really on?
There might not be time to angst over incest
– because the white walkers are coming to
attack Winterfell . Jaime Lannister arrives,
and says he’ll help “fight for the living”
. Last season, Jaime promised to help fight
the white walkers , and now, he wants to keep
that pledge.
Jaime has always been hated as an oathbreaker
and kingslayer – this war is Jaime’s chance
at redemption.
He’s got a lot of crimes to redeem – last
time he was at Winterfell, Jaime crippled
Bran.
Jaime fought Ned, and warred against Robb.
Will the Starks make alliance with their enemy?
Probably.
Because as Jon says, everyone alive is “on
the same side” now – fighting against
the dead.
So everyone prepares for battle at Winterfell.
We see Davos on the walls – even though
he isn’t much of a fighter . We see Edd,
Tormund and Beric.
It looked like Beric and Tormund mighta died
last season when the Wall fell – but they’ve
survived to fight again.
Edd became commander of the Night’s Watch
when Jon left – now looks like he musta
ran south when the Wall fell.
But how much of the Night’s Watch survived?
Maybe with the white walkers coming, everyone
is Night’s Watch now.
We see Gendry with a big pile of dragonglass,
mined from Dragonstone – Gendry’ll need
to make a bunch of weapons to fight the dead.
But hopefully there’ll also be time for
him to reunite with his old friend Arya.
We see Jorah and the Dothraki.
Jorah has the sword Heartsbane.
This is the Valyrian sword of House Tarly
that Sam took from his dad.
But Sam isn’t good with a sword, so it makes
sense he’d give Heartsbane to Jorah – they
made friends last season.
We see Brienne and Podrick with the knights
of the Vale – these guys only came north
to help fight the Boltons, they never signed
up for this World War Z shit.
But again, everyone’s coming together to
fight the dead.
We see Grey Worm kiss Missandei – while
Jon’s voiceover says that the white walkers
don’t feel . This is a reminder of why everyone’s
fighting.
This war isn’t for a lord or a throne – this
is about the survival of life and love itself
against the cold dead enemy.
Grey Worm looks intense as he prepares for
battle.
The Unsullied were bred to be emotionless
, but with Missandei, Grey Worm has found
a something worth fighting for . There are
trebuchets behind the Unsullied, maybe to
throw fire at the dead.
While the warriors prepare for battle, we
see women and children and Varys in the crypts.
This is like the battle of Helm’s Deep in
Lord of the Rings – a Game of Thrones director
said he studied that battle for this episode
. Varys looks scared and out of place, when
he used to be so confident and powerful in
the politics of King’s Landing.
How can Varys stay relevant in this magical
apocalyptic finale?
We should, at least, get some good conversations
here during the battle – it could be like
in the Red Keep during the battle of the Blackwater.
In the background, we see Gilly and her baby.
Remember, this baby was originally meant to
be sacrificed to the white walkers, and when
Gilly took the baby south instead, the walkers
came after him . It’s possible that the
walkers still want Gilly’s baby.
It’s also possible that the dead might rise
from these crypts – there are hints in the
books about ancient Starks with white walker
blood, go watch that video.
The battle for Winterfell begins.
Brienne and Jaime fight the dead on the walls.
Brienne wields the Valyrian sword Oathkeeper,
while Jaime uses Widow’s Wail.
Both these swords were made from the Stark
sword Ice.
So the reunion of Brienne and Jaime has all
sorts of symbolic weight to it.
This is also kinda like a dream Jaime has
in the books, where he and Brienne wield flaming
swords, and face the dead amidst darkness
and doom . Which connects to the prophecy
of Azor Ahai, and Nissa Nissa, and maybe the
deaths of Jaime and Brienne.
We see the Hound amidst fire.
And the Hound is afraid of fire, because when
he was young, his brother the Mountain burned
his face.
Fire is why the Hound ran from battle in Season
2, and was afraid of Beric in Season 3.
Maybe now, the Hound will face his fear to
defeat the dead who haunt him – both metaphorically
and literally.
Cause it’s hinted that the Hound will face
the Mountain in a fight called Cleganebowl.
Since the Mountain is undead, the Hound might
need fire to defeat him.
We also see Jon running, doing something heroic
– in the books, he also has a dream of fighting
the dead with fire.
We see horses running across snow, and it
looks like there might be some wolves in there
as well.
We might see Jon’s direwolf Ghost, or even
the wolf pack led by Arya’s direwolf, Nymeria.
We see Arya doing some spin moves with a stick
– like the Faceless Men trained her.
Or maybe it’s a dragonglass spear to kill
the dead.
But her victim here has a lot of blood – zombies
don’t usually bleed that much.
Remember, the white walkers can also raise
animals, like polar bears, and there are stories
of giant ice spiders . The night is dark and
full of terrors, and Arya may face them.
Arya says “I know Death.
He's got many faces.
I look forward to seeing this one” . Cause
remember, the Faceless Men taught Arya about
the Many-Faced God, a name for Death.
The Night King, leader of the white walkers,
is an embodiment of death – a symbol of
the people Arya’s killed, and maybe of her
own death.
Arya takes a dragonglass dagger, to kill white
walkers, but it looks like things go badly
for her.
The trailer starts with Arya looking scared
and hurt in the dark – she’s got a wound
on her head, and she’s running in terror.
When was the last time Arya looked so scared?
It looks like Arya is running from zombies,
but why’s she so afraid if she’s a dragonglass
dagger and Valyrian blade?
Maybe those zombies were people she knew.
Maybe they’re dead Starks risen from the
crypts, her mother or her brother.
One way or another, it looks like death is
catching up with Arya.
In Book 1, Jon jokes that Arya will die in
the winter – that they’ll find her body
with a needle still locked tight between her
fingers .
So at Winterfell, almost every character is
desperately fighting for the survival of all
life.
But down in King’s Landing, Cersei is scheming
to save herself.
She’s got a shiny new outfit, looking smug
and powerful – and she’s with her two
best friends, the creepy mad scientist Qyburn,
and the zombie Mountain.
Most everyone else has died or abandoned her,
including Jaime.
Last season, Cersei sent Euron Greyjoy to
buy a mercenary group called the Golden Company.
Here they’re on Euron’s ships, with their
leader “Homeless” Harry Strickland.
The Golden Company is said to be “the most
powerful army in Essos”, with twenty thousand
men, horses, and elephants . So we finally
gonna get some oliphont action in Game of
Thrones.
In the books, the Golden Company has a complex
plotline involving the Blackfyres, and a kid
called Young Griff.
None of that seems to be happening in the
show – the Company is just here to help
Cersei cling to the Throne until the bitter
end.
This looks like Strickland standing before
Cersei on the Throne, with the Mountain and
Qyburn, but this character is unclear – maybe
Euron, or the banker Tycho Nestoris, or even
Sansa with the red hair?
It’s hard to tell.
In this shot, Cersei looks more vulnerable
– she’s got sort of a smile, but also
tears in her eyes.
She’s drinking wine, which is weird, cause
last season, Cersei said she was pregnant.
Maybe Cersei loses her unborn child – and
with nothing left to protect, she’ll unleash
her full fury upon Westeros.
There also this weird shot.
Maybe it’s Jon at Winterfell – or maybe
it’s Arya in King’s Landing – that could
be a brazier in the Great Hall.
It looks she’s holding a bow, and we know
Arya can use a bow.
Maybe this shot is Arya is trying to kill
Cersei, like she said she would last season
. Will Arya kill the queen?
There are rumours that this’ll be the only
trailer for Season 8 – so this might be
the last ever trailer for Game of Thrones.
We’re gonna make the most of the final season
– so make sure you subscribe and click the
bell.
Analysing a new Game of Thrones trailer is
like solving a puzzle.
You gotta find connections between bits of
information, to find an explanation that makes
sense.
If you like puzzles, you might like the new
Daily Problems on Brilliant, teaching maths,
science, engineering and computer science.
Each Daily Problem explores a concept, like
the Cosmic Microwave Background , or how to
slice a donut . Then it gives you a problem
that you can solve with that information.
If you need help with problem, there are other
users discussing the solution.
So next time you’ve got a spare five minutes,
you can learn something new – and get a
little smarter each day.
Sign up for free at brilliant.org/AltShiftX,
and the first 200 to sign up can get 20% off
an annual Premium subscription – to unlock
the archive of Daily Problems and dozens of
courses, on maths, science, space, donuts,
and beyond.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to the Patrons,
including Matthew Ungar, Emily N, Ando, Jason
Rankin, Ashley Smith, Andreas Constantin Roders-Arnold,
Brandon Bouchaya, and Steven Placencia.
Cheers.